a panacea is defined as a remedy for all
difficulties and diseases it is a
medicine potion or other item that can
pull a patient back from the brink of
death and save someone from even the
worst of circumstances a cure-all it's a
wonderful idea one that would save
countless lives put a stop to untold
needless suffering and improve the human
experience on a permanent global scale
unfortunately anyone claiming to have
the solution to all problems is likely
just trying to sell you something unless
of course that person works at the scp
foundation then they just might be
telling you the truth because they just
might be telling you about scp-500
scp-500 also known as the panacea is
completely unassuming in appearance all
it consists of is a single plastic pill
bottle filled with exactly 47 red pills
this is all that remains of the world's
only known miracle cure when the pills
were first discovered by the foundation
they were used in a variety of
experiments in order to determine the
limits if any of their curative powers
they tested the pills on everything from
diseases like cancer to physical
injuries like a broken femur in each and
every case one pill taken orally cured
the test subject of all symptoms within
a matter of hours after determining that
scp-500 could treat natural ailments the
foundation scientists decided to apply
it to more unnatural ills two pills were
authorized for use with
scp-008 to be administered to class d
personnel who had been exposed to it at
the time of this experiment's approval
there were 57 pills in the can scp-008
is a complex prion or a misfolded
protein with the ability to change the
shape of correctly formed variants of
the same protein brions are considered
to be the cause of mad cow disease among
many other debilitating
neurodegenerative diseases
scp-008 is no exception to the
devastation it takes what is terrifying
about other prion diseases the loss of
cognition the onset of dementia the
certain death and cranks it up to 11. 20
hours after the onset of symptoms the
infected person will slip into a coma
but that is not the end of their
suffering the nervous system is damaged
and the cells have begun to necrotize
but the infected person is still able to
move they shamble around on two legs
they crawl they grab and they bite they
seek out stimuli that indicate the
presence of a living uninfected human
and they will attempt to devour it the
only way to stop an infected individual
is to completely destroy their brain
essentially it is a zombie plague
understandably the foundation has a
vested interest in curing and containing
scp-008 and so the promise of the
panacea was an enticing one for the
purposes of the experiment a member of
the class-d personnel was randomly
selected and exposed to scp-008
within three hours he began to exhibit
symptoms running a fever of 105 degrees
and coughing and vomiting uncontrollably
wanting to see if it would be possible
to use scp-500 as a cure even in the
latest stages of the disease the
scientists conducting the experiment
allowed the symptoms to progress with
the test subject eventually slipping
into a coma once comatose the cell
degeneration quickened until he began to
move again his dull unfocused eyes
roamed around the room and he lurched
towards a member of the research staff
biting down on her arm of course she was
clad in hazmat gear in order to prevent
infection but the class d no longer had
the cognitive capacity to understand
that the researcher seized the
opportunity to wrench his jaws open and
stuff one of the scp-500 pills down his
throat once the pill had been swallowed
she vacated the room and the test
subject was quarantined after two hours
the research team returned to
investigate the results of their test
what they found was something amazing
sitting in the cell was a completely
lucid healthy if a bit confused man with
no signs of the disease that had
previously ravaged his body the panacea
was able to cure scp-008
even at its most advanced stages so they
knew that scp-500 could cure a prion
disease like 008 but what else could it
cure what was the extent of its
marvelous medical power if any could it
cure an ailment with virtually no basis
in modern medical understanding next one
pill was approved and allocated for
testing with scp-409
scp-409 is a rock formation resembling a
large quartz crystal it is kept in a
sealed granite case and no one is
permitted to touch it with any substance
other than granite unless during active
experimentation anyone who comes into
physical contact with
scp-409 suffers a peculiar and
nightmarish fate they will immediately
begin to crystallize their body
effectively turning into rock the
crystallization occurs at a rate of
roughly one inch per minute and will
continue until the victim's entire body
inside and out has solidified it is an
incredibly painful process and thought
to be completely irreversible subject
409-d5 was chosen at random from a group
of class-d personnel as the guinea pig
for the next scp-500 experiment he was
exposed to a
scp-409 touching it with his index
finger this small touch was more than
enough to seal his fate upon contact the
finger immediately began to crystallize
spreading up his hand his wrist and his
arm over the course of several minutes
as he screamed in agony it was difficult
to administer scp-500 with all this
screaming but a researcher was able to
close his mouth long enough for the pill
to be swallowed within a few hours the
foundation researchers watched as the
crystallization process slowed and then
stopped after nine days in a foundation
hospital ward the crystallization
process had completely reversed and the
man was returned to normal he still
reported phantom pain in the formerly
crystallized parts of his body but even
that cleared up after several more days
after the incredible success of the
scp-008 and scp-409 trials the
foundation was desperate to synthesize
their own version of scp-500
a multitude of experiments were
performed in an attempt to isolate the
active ingredient in the pills but every
time they found what appeared to be the
miracle aspect of the anomalous pills
they found that they were unable to
synthesize it and have it produce the
same results as the real thing extensive
drug trials were conducted leaving a
trail of injured and dead d-class
personnel in their wake with the
traditional pharmacological route
eliminated the foundation decided to
expose some of the pills to a variety of
other scps in an attempt to somehow
recreate or amplify their effects most
of the results were lackluster or
completely uneventful however some did
yield notable results one pill was taken
from scp-500 and placed inside of
scp-914
which is a large clockwork device with a
multitude of settings ranging from very
fine to rough that is capable of
transforming matter in various ways the
pill was run through scp-914 on the fine
setting and the machine produced a small
silver locket which would later be
classified as scp-427
scp-427 retains some of the healing
properties of its original form able to
regenerate damaged cells and purge
infection from the body when it is
opened and exposed to a living subject
during testing it was able to cure the
common cold in a matter of minutes
however unlike scp-500 the lock had
produced notable negative side effects
prolonged exposure to scp-427's healing
properties increased cell regeneration
and the optimization of bodily systems
beyond a healthy threshold exposure for
more than an hour turn the test subjects
into shapeless masses of tissue
nicknamed flesh beasts these flesh
beasts are highly aggressive and will
attack anything in sight unless they are
put down
scp-427 was intended to be a potential
replacement for scp-5000 once the
limited number of pills ran out but the
potential risks of its use have led to
it being shelved indefinitely with all
attempts to create a different yet
equally effective version of scp-500
ending in failure the foundation instead
tried to find a way to duplicate it in
one case an experiment was conducted
with the intent to produce more of the
panacea pills not using chemistry and
compounding but instead opting for a
much more unusual method after a request
was submitted and approved five pills
from the bottle were selected to be
exposed to scp-038
scp-038 is a highly unique plant
resembling a common apple tree however
it can grow far more than just apples
the tree can clone any object that
touches its bark producing the clone on
its branches where an ordinary tree
would bear fruit the five allocated
pills were touched to the fabric of the
tree and sure enough clones of the red
capsules began to sprout within seconds
but while the tree was able to clone
pills that looked identical to scp-500
their effectiveness was sorely lacking
compared to the originals clone pills
were only approximately 30 percent
effective in curing the infections they
were used to treat as opposed to the 100
effectiveness with the real deal the
clone pills were set aside for treatment
of less severe infections and all the
originals were returned to their storage
container well almost all of them as the
experiment was wrapping up a d-class
participating in the experiment managed
to pocket one of the five pills
allocated for the test the pill's
absence was not noticed until the
following day at which point it had
already been ingested by the thief when
interrogated the man admitted that he
had stolen the pill in order to cure a
particularly nasty hangover after his
usual method of pickle juice a bacon
sandwich and aspirin had failed the
employee was promptly terminated and
security around scp-500 was tightened
significantly following this incident no
personnel below level 3 were permitted
to handle scp-500 in any capacity when
it was initially brought into the
foundation there were approximately 57
pills in scp-500 container and currently
only 47 remain
due to the limited amount of pills and
inability thus far to duplicate them in
an equivalently effective form
experimentation with scp-500 has been
drastically limited most requests for
experimentation or allocation of pills
are promptly denied these requests have
included a dr gibbons who asked that two
pills be given to him for his personal
medkit as well as a proposed experiment
involving scp-253
a group of cells which bear some strong
resemblances to cancer several concerned
personnel at the foundation have worried
that scp-500 may have another anomalous
effect that it may cause obsessive
fixation in those who spend a great deal
of time with it leading them to
experiment with it again and again
unable to let it go until they crack an
unsolvable code
this has been immediately dismissed as
trivial and unfounded by the scp-500
research team surely their obsessive
work with the pills is their own choice
but perhaps the concerned parties have a
point after all there are a few things
more compelling than a miracle cure and
there is arguably no greater scientific
discovery that could be made no higher
mountain than one could climb and there
is nothing more maddening than having
that life-saving pill in your grasp and
watch the number dwindle down one pill
at a time like grains of sand slipping
between your fingers with only 47 pills
left and no way to recreate them on the
horizon perhaps the panacea is both a
blessing and a curse a tantalizing
glimpse at what humanity could have but
will never truly achieve but hey maybe
they'll crack the code if they just try
one more experiment and why not try
there will still be 46 left and then 45
and then
well let's just hope they figure it out
before they truly are all gone now go
check out
scp-999 the tickle monster and the
ipod's
scp-131 for more helpful anomalies